David Boder: [In English] This is Spool No. 15 taken at Boucicaut, France near Paris, August 1, 1946. The interviewee is a young girl, Fela Nichthauser. She is so accustomed that when her last name is called first, that when I asked her about her last name...about her first name, she said “Nichthauser,” and as her last name she said “Fela.” That comes from being constantly on roll call.
David Boder: [In German] Sagen Sie mir mal, Fela, was ist Ihr voller Name? Was ist Ihr Name?
Fela Nichthauser: Was heißt voller Name?
David Boder: Ihr Name, was ist Ihr Name?
Fela Nichthauser: Fela Nichthauser.
David Boder: Fela Nichthauser. Und wie alt sind Sie, Fela?
Fela Nichthauser: Drei und zwanzig (23) Jahre.
David Boder: Sie sind drei und zwanzig (23) Jahre alt. Und wo wohnen Sie jetzt?
Fela Nichthauser: Jetzt bin ich (unverständlich—spricht so leise, dass man es nicht verstehen kann)
David Boder: Wo wohnen Sie hier?
Fela Nichthauser: Nicht im Chateau, ich wohne ein paar Häuser weiter, aber...
David Boder: Sie wohnen nicht im Boucicaut?
Fela Nichthauser: Nicht im Boucicaut, auch in einem Heim von OSE.
David Boder: Auch in einem Heim von OSE. Sind dort noch andere Mädchen?
Fela Nichthauser: Nein, da sind keine deportierten Menschen. Das ist ein Kinderheim und ich bin dort nur ausnahmsweise, weil ich in Chateau Boucicaut meinen Bruder habe...
David Boder: Oh!
Fela Nichthauser: . . . und damit wir zusammen sind, haben sie das gemacht, obwohl ich dort nicht arbeite. Ich gehe in eine Schule in Paris.
David Boder: Sie besuchen eine Schule in Paris. Was für eine Schule ist das?
Fela Nichthauser: Zahntechniker Schule—auch von OSE.
David Boder: Und Sie lernen Zahntechniker? Hat die OSE ihre eigene Zahntechniker Schule?
Fela Nichthauser: Ja - jawohl, OSE hat seine eigene Schule hier.
David Boder: Und wie viele Leute studieren dort?
Fela Nichthauser: Gegen siebzig (70), siebzig (70) oder fünf und siebzig (75) Schüler.
David Boder: Ja. Und sie denken, dass Zahntechniker ist ein gutes Fach für ein Mädchen?
Fela Nichthauser: Ich weiß das nicht genau. Aber ich bin ganz alleine im Leben und ich muss...da, ganz alleine alles entscheiden und hoffe ich, wenn nicht das, dann Anderes vielleicht, ich weiß es selbst nicht.
David Boder: Ist Ihr Bruder jetzt hier?
Fela Nichthauser: Nein, mein Bruder ist jetzt auf ‚vakant’ geschickt...ans Meer.
David Boder: Und wer sind die anderen Kinder, die dort im OSE leben?
Fela Nichthauser: Das sind auch...die meisten sind Buchenwald Kinder.
David Boder: Auch Buchenwald Kinder?
Fela Nichthauser: Ja, und es sind auch ein paar französische Kinder, die nicht deportiert waren.
David Boder: Und wie viel Mädchen sind hier?
Fela Nichthauser: Elf Mädel.
David Boder: Elf Mädel.
Fela Nichthauser: Elf Mädel und eine ist noch deportiert und das Übrige sind, die Familie haben hier oder keine Eltern.
David Boder: Nun sagen Sie Mal, Fela, Sie sind jetzt drei und zwanzig (23) Jahre alt, wo sind Sie geboren?
Fela Nichthauser: Ich bin geboren in Polen...in der Stadt Wadowice.
David Boder: In Wadowice. Nun erzählen Sie, was hat dort passiert, wenn die Deutsche rüber kamen?
Fela Nichthauser: Im Jahre neun und dreißig (39), wenn der Krieg ausgebrochen ist, sind alle Leute...sind wir, sowie alle Leute, geflüchtet. Wir hatten eigene, hm, Pferde zu Hause und eigenen Wagen und unsere ganze Familie...also nicht die ganze Familie, der Papa, die Mutti, zwei Brüder und ich, sind wir geflüchtet worden, sehr weit—hinter Sandomierz.
David Boder: Hm, was war Ihr Vater’s Geschäft?
Fela Nichthauser: Geflügel Händler.
David Boder: Er war ein...
Fela Nichthauser: Geflügel Händler und Fisch Händler.
David Boder: In der Stadt?
Fela Nichthauser: In der Stadt, ja. Er hat eine ganz große Halle gehabt.
David Boder: Ja. War das en gros? Hat er das zu andere Geschäfte verkauft?
Fela Nichthauser: Ja.
David Boder: Ja. Und wozu hatten Sie die Pferde und Wagen.
Fela Nichthauser: Weil, ausserdem hat mein Vater Kohle...ein, hm,...
David Boder: Sagen Sie es polisch.
Fela Nichthauser: (spricht polnisch) Wie heisst das?
David Boder: Skrado...was?
Fela Nichthauser: Wo man Kohle verkauft.
David Boder: Kohle, ja. Er hat ein Kohlenlager gehabt
Fela Nichthauser: Kohlenlager hat er gehabt.
David Boder: Sie hatten ihre eigenen Wagen und Pferde.
Fela Nichthauser: Wagen und Pferde, ja, damit wir können die Kohle von andere Städte...
David Boder: Herbringen.
Fela Nichthauser: . . . herbringen und dann verkaufen.
David Boder: . . . und dann verkaufen. Und so haben Sie Wagen und Pferde genommen und sind weg gefahren. Wer sind Sie alle weg gefahren? Ihr Vater, ihre Mutter, wer noch?
Fela Nichthauser: Zwei Brüder, zwei jüngere Brüder und ich.
David Boder: Sind Sie die Älteste in der Familie?
Fela Nichthauser: Nein, ich habe noch eine verheiratete Schwester gehabt, die noch vor dem Krieg an der russischen Grenze gewohnt hat, das heißt in Baranowicz. Und schon im Jahre neun und dreißig (39) haben wir keine Nachricht mehr von ihr gehabt. Man weiß bis jetzt nicht, was ist geschehen.
David Boder: Ist Baranowicz nicht weit von Slonim?
Fela Nichthauser: Ich glaube ja.
David Boder: Sie glauben. Nun, ja, also Einer von diesen zwei Brüdern ist jetzt mit Ihnen hier?
Fela Nichthauser: Ja mit mir hier. Und der Andere war auch mit dem Kleinen zusammen in Buchenwald. Und das Schicksal wollte, dass ein paar Tage vor der Befreiung—drei (3) oder vier (4) Tage vor der Befreiung, bevor die Engländer gekommen sind...die Amerikaner gekommen sind, dass man hat weg geschickt auf einen Transport, weil er sich noch bewegen konnte als Gesunde...und auf dem Wege hat man den ganzen Transport erschossen.
David Boder: Man hat den ganzen Transport erschossen?
Fela Nichthauser: Ja.
David Boder: So hier ist der ältere Bruder?
Fela Nichthauser: Nein, der Jüngste.
David Boder: Der Jüngste.
Fela Nichthauser: Der Jüngste von der ganzen Familie.
David Boder: Und wieso hat man ihn nicht mitgenommen?
Fela Nichthauser: Weil er war schwer krank interniert.
David Boder: Er war schwer krank interniert in Buchenwald, ja.
Fela Nichthauser: Er hat überhaupt nicht gewusst, dass man seinen Bruder genommen hat.
David Boder: Nun also, so sind Sie mit ihren Eltern nach Radomir, sagen Sie?
Fela Nichthauser: Nein, nach Sandomierz geflüchtet...
David Boder: Sandomierz...
Fela Nichthauser: . . . und wir wollten weiter, aber dann haben wir erfahren dass die Deutschen sind schon da und wir mussten zurück nach Hause fahren. Und da hat man...da hat man uns alles gestohlen. Und wir hatten einen großen Garten zu Hause, das hat man alles zerstört und so dass wir ohne Nichts geblieben sind. Wir waren damals fünf Personen, wir hatten keinen Groschen zum Leben und ich musste sehr, sehr schwer arbeiten mit meinem Vater, mit Mutti und meine Brüdern nur für ein paar Mark, damit wir die Wohnung bezahlen können und damit wir auch Brot haben.
David Boder: Haben Sie nicht in ihrem eigenen Hause gelebt? Hatten Sie nicht ein Haus?
Fela Nichthauser: Ein Haus haben wir nicht gehabt. Wir haben nur...mein Vater hat nur gemietet von dem Haus, mein Vater was (unverständlich—spricht zu leise)...
David Boder: . . . von dem Haus, ja. Also Sie sind dann zurück gekommen nach...
Fela Nichthauser: . . . nach Polen zurück in der selben Stadt...
David Boder: Welche Stadt war das?
Fela Nichthauser: Also nicht derselben, heißt Andrychów dann die Stadt.
David Boder: Sie sind zurück nach Andrychów gekommen?
Fela Nichthauser: Ja.
David Boder: Und was hat dann Ihr Vater getan?
Fela Nichthauser: Auf der Strasse gearbeitet mit der Schaufel, weil es die Deutschen verlangt.
David Boder: Die Deutschen haben es verlangt?
Fela Nichthauser: Ja, Alle Männer hat man auf die Strasse zur Arbeit genommen und jüdische Mädel hat man zum Fußboden scheuern genommen oder Fenster auf dem vierten (4.) Stock zu putzen.
David Boder: Für wen?
Fela Nichthauser: Für die Deutschen, für die Polizei, für alle. Und ich war auch dabei, aber weil ich...weil ich gut gearbeitet hab und schwer gearbeitet hab, weil ich wollte...ich wollte damit zu, hm, gehen zu dem Leutnant und ihn bitten, ich soll nicht umsonst arbeiten und dann soll er mehr bezahlen. ,
David Boder: Ja.
Fela Nichthauser: Weil alle anderen Menschen haben nur umsonst gearbeitet.
David Boder: So...?
Fela Nichthauser: . . . denn sie haben Essen bekommen drei Mal täglich und das hat nicht viel geholfen, weil ich hab damals fünfzehn bis achtzehn Mark verdient und das war bei denen sehr viel. Und mein Papa hat auch verdient...einige Juden auch, die gut gearbeitet haben.
David Boder: Ja, haben Sie nicht etwas Geld versteckt gehabt, etwas Sachen...? (beide sprechen)
Fela Nichthauser: Nein, nein, so gut ist es uns eigentlich nicht gegangen, dass wir etwas zu verstecken hatten, weil wir waren eine ganz große Familie—fünf (5) Kinder—und fünf (5) unerwachsene Kinder, die noch kein Geld nicht verdienen konnten, so dass alles lag auf dem Rücken von den Eltern.
David Boder: Ja, nun sagen Sie mal, Sie sagen, Sie haben Pferde gehabt und Wagen?
Fela Nichthauser: Ja, gut...(beide sprechen)
David Boder: Sind Sie mit diesem Pferdewagen zurück gekommen?
Fela Nichthauser: Ja, zurück gekommen mir einem Pferd; ein Pferd wird erschossen.
David Boder: Wer hat das Pferd erschossen?
Fela Nichthauser: Oh, ein, ein...ein Stückchen von einer Granate.
David Boder: Oh, ein Stückchen von einer Grate, wieso sind da Granaten gekommen?
Fela Nichthauser: Weil wir sind jetzt zurück gekommen mit dem polnischen Militär. Wir haben...wir...(beide sprechen)
David Boder: Oh, ja.
Fela Nichthauser: . . . wir haben sie unterwegs getroffen, so dass viele, viele andere Wagen mit Zivilleuten sind eben zwischen das Militär gekommen. Und das war eben das Schlimmste.
David Boder: Warum?
Fela Nichthauser: Weil man hat doch geschossen, man hat doch gewusst, dass dort das polnische Militär geht. Die Deutschen haben das gewusst und haben ständig geschossen und wir haben gelebt andauernd in einer schrecklichen Angst. Wir konnten uns nicht rühren, um etwas zum Essen zu holen oder sonst was, weil es war gefährlich.
David Boder: Nun und was passierte dann?
Fela Nichthauser: Dann war ich zwei Jahre zu Hause und im Jahre vierzig (40) kam der allererste Schlag, weil man hat mit dem ersten Transport meinen Bruder geschickt, der damals siebzehn (17) Jahre war und das war schrecklich. Mein Papa wollte nicht, dass er alleine ins Lager geht und hat er sich freiwillig gemeldet als sechs und fünfzig (56) jähriger Mann. Und es hat nichts geholfen, dass meine Mutti ihn gebeten hat und ich ihn gebeten habe, er soll nicht von uns weg fahren, es wird für uns viel schwerer. Er hat gesagt, er lässt das Kind alleine nicht ins Lager zu den Deutschen. Er muss weg fahren. Und so hat man ihn angenommen, gerne die Deutschen haben es gemacht. Und so ist mein Papa im Jahre vierzig (40) mit meinem Bruder ins Lager weg gefahren. Dann...
David Boder: Ja?
Fela Nichthauser: . . . dann war es schon sehr schwer, denn ich musste arbeiten mit dem zwölf- (12) jährigen Kind; er hat auch mit einer Schaufel auf der Strasse gearbeitet. Wir mussten Wohnung bezahlen und Essen kaufen und Lebensmittel kaufen und Pakete ins Lager schicken.
David Boder: Hat man erlaubt Pakete ins...? (beide sprechen)
Fela Nichthauser: Ja, man durfte zwei (2) Kilo Pakete pro Mann schicken.
David Boder: Wie weit war das Lager von zu Hause?
Fela Nichthauser: Es war sehr weit. Der Papa war dann noch mit dem Bruder in verschiedenen Lagern. Das erste Lager war Wischau...
David Boder: Aha.
Fela Nichthauser: . . . das befindet sich in Deutschland. Ich weiß nicht wo. Dann war er in Flessing, das ist bei Gleiwitz. Dann war er in Blechhammer bei Sakrow, das letzte Lager war Dachau.
David Boder: Das letzte Lager war Dachau?
Fela Nichthauser: Nach einem Jahr ist der Bruder zurück gekommen—befreit, weil er hat einen schrecklichen Fuß gehabt. Er hat sich selber das gemacht und...so dass man ihn nach Hause frei gelassen hat.
David Boder: Die Deutschen?
Fela Nichthauser: Die Deutschen, ja.
David Boder: Ja.
Fela Nichthauser: Und der Papa ist geblieben.
David Boder: Aha.
Fela Nichthauser: Und seit dieser Zeit wissen wir nichts.
David Boder: Ja.
Fela Nichthauser: Dann, hm, dann blieb ich noch ein Jahr zu Hause; und im Jahr ein und vierzig (41) wurde die ganze Stadt ausgesiedelt. Das war zwei (2) Wochen nach der Befreiung von meinem Bruder, wo er vom Lager gekommen ist.
Fela Nichthauser: Meine Mutti hat gearbeitet in einer anderen Stadt, um zu...um Sonderkarte zu erhalten, dass sie arbeitet und man soll sie nicht weg schicken. Hat sie dort gearbeitet und wir drei (3) Kinder, meine Brüder und ich haben wir in der Stadt gearbeitet auf der Strasse. Und an dem Tag, das war am dritten (3.) Juni im Jahr ein und vierzig (41) wurde die ganze Stadt gerufen auf einen ganz großen Platz.
David Boder: Nur die Juden?
Fela Nichthauser: Nur die Juden, natürlich, um uns auszusiedeln.
David Boder: Ja.
Fela Nichthauser: Und wir...
David Boder: Und was war wieder der Name von der Stadt?
Fela Nichthauser: Andrychów.
David Boder: Andrychów und in welchem Distrikt ist es?
Fela Nichthauser: Das war Kreis Bielitz...
David Boder: Bielitz?
Fela Nichthauser: Bielitz.
David Boder: Ja und nun?
Fela Nichthauser: Geboren bin ich in Wadowice, aber dann haben wir gewohnt...
David Boder: In Beletz.
Fela Nichthauser: Nein in Andrychów.
David Boder: In Andrychów.
Fela Nichthauser: Ja, das ist nicht weit.
David Boder: Also man hat die ganze Stadt zusammen gerufen. So wo war Ihre Mutter?
Fela Nichthauser: Mein Mutter war eben in der anderen Stadt.
David Boder: Ja. Wo war das?
Fela Nichthauser: Das war zwölf (12) Kilometer...
David Boder: Oh, das war zwölf (12) Kilometer weit weg.
Fela Nichthauser: Ja. Sie ist am Abend immer weggefahren, weil sie hat Nachtschicht gehabt und ging um sechs (6) zum Bahnhof und wir begleiteten sie noch, sie hat uns geküsst und hat uns noch einige Befehle gegeben, was wir bis morgen machen sollen und wir haben leider dabei nicht gewusst, dass wir die Mutti das letzte Mal gesehen haben.
David Boder: Aha.
Fela Nichthauser: Und dann am nächsten Tag um sechs (6) Uhr wir sind aufgestanden, um so wie gewöhnlich zur Arbeit. Es war ein schöner Tag, es hat überhaupt nicht in der Luft gehangen...gehangen—wir haben überhaupt nicht gedacht, dass es so etwas Schreckliches kommen kann. Und da kamen zwei (2) jüdische Polizisten und zwei (2) SS Männer und die haben gesagt, wir sollen sofort auf den Sammelplatz gehen.
David Boder: Ja. Haben Sie denen gesagt, dass Ihre Mutter in der anderen Stadt...(beide sprechen)
Fela Nichthauser: Hab ich ihnen gesagt, weil ich bin noch so dumm gewesen—ich hab nicht geglaubt, dass diese Detuschen so schlecht sein können und mich auslachen werden, wenn ich ihnen sage, ich muss auf meine Mutti warten, weil sie um sechs (6) Uhr hierher kommt. Haben sie mir gesagt, ich soll mich nicht um die Mutti kümmern, die Mutti wird schon kommen. Und so mussten wir gehen auf den Sammelplatz und dort hat sich Schreckliches, hm, vorgespielt—Schreckliches, das werde ich nie vergessen.
David Boder: Was hat dort passiert?
Fela Nichthauser: Man hat dort genommen nicht nur die Gesunden, sondern ganz alte Menschen, die sich überhaupt nicht bewegen konnten, die sehr krank waren. Ich selbst, ich persönlich, habe ich eine...habe ich gesehen, wie man siebzig (70) jährige Frau, ganz geschwollen von der Krankheit hat man geschleppt auf dem Gras, weil man hat sich geekelt sie aufzuheben. Weil sie war ganz weich von dem Geschwollenen. Und da konnte ich nicht zuschauen und da hat man mir erlaubt, dass ich mithelfe die Frau aufzuheben und auf die Stiegen rauf in ein Bett geht in einem großen Saal.
David Boder: Ja nun?
Fela Nichthauser: Und man hat gesehen verschiedene Dinge, die ich wirklich nicht vergessen kann. Man hat dann die Leute geteilt, man stand...
David Boder: Also was ist Ihnen passiert, erzählen Sie mir das, ja?
Fela Nichthauser: Also wir...
David Boder: Sie waren mit einem Bruder?
Fela Nichthauser: Mit zwei(2) Brüdern.
David Boder: Mit zwei(2) Brüdern.
Fela Nichthauser: Mit dem, der aus dem Lager gekommen ist
David Boder: Und wo ist er jetzt—der aus dem Lager gekommen ist?
Fela Nichthauser: Er lebt nicht...er lebt nicht mehr, das ist der, den man vor der Befreiung auf Transport geschickt...
David Boder: Aha. Der war nachher in Buchenwald und...
Fela Nichthauser: . . . mit dem Kleinen.
David Boder: Also er ist zurück gekommen und dann ist er wieder in einem Lager...
Fela Nichthauser: Nein, aber das ist wie wir auf den Sammelplatz gekommen sind.
David Boder: Sie meinen Sie und Ihre zwei (2) Brüder.
Fela Nichthauser: Ich und meine zwei (2) Brüder.
David Boder: Nun?
Fela Nichthauser: Und da standen wir vor einer Kommission und sie haben uns Verschiedenes gefragt und wir haben die Arbeitskarten gezeigt und man hat gesehen, dass wir Drei (3) jung und gesund sind und man hat gesagt, man soll uns alle Drei ins Lager schicken. Und es war die Sache erledigt und ich werd schon nicht erzählen vielleicht die ganzen Szenen.
David Boder: Ich will aber, dass mir alles erzählen, erzählen Sie mir was passiert...
Fela Nichthauser: Mein Onkel ist dort gestanden mit drei Kindern.
David Boder: Alles was Sie selbst gesehen haben, das erzählen Sie, nicht wahr. Ja, Ihr Onkel ist gestanden dort...
Fela Nichthauser: Weil man hat alle Leute in Gruppen geteilt. Junge Menschen ins Lager, alte Menschen auf einen Transport, das heißt, nach Auschwitz und noch einige Menschen, die noch in der selben Stadt geblieben konnten...zu arbeiten. Also es waren drei Gruppen. Und man hat gesehen...und das Herz hat schrecklich weh getan, wenn man hat gesehen, diese Leute hatten von der Bewegung eines deutschen Mannes hat es abgehangen, das Schicksal von den Menschen. Er hat so gemacht mit der Hand oder so. Das hat geheißen, ob er ins Lager kommt—also er konnte ja damals glücklich sein, wenn er ins Lager konnte. Und wenn nicht, dann auf die linke Seite und das heißt nach Auschwitz, von wo schon niemand zurück gekommen ist. Mein Onkel auch mit drei (3) Kinder stand auch auf der Seite, wo die Aussiedlung war. Und seine Frau ist mit meiner Mutti eben gearbeitet. Und da hat er schrecklich geweint und die Kinder haben sich ihm so...an den Füßen gehalten und sie haben alle schrecklich geweint und sie haben mich gesehen und er hat geschrien, ich soll seine Frau grüßen. Er hat nicht gewusst, dass ich ins Lager komme, er hat geglaubt, dass ich noch heute seine Frau sehen werde. Und da hat er mich gebeten, ich soll seine Frau grüßen, er wird zurück kommen und er wird schützen die drei (3) Kinder und es wird den Kindern nichts passieren. Und ich habe eben gesehen sein sehr trauriges Gesicht und die kleinen Kinder und das kann ich nie vergessen. Da stand eben neben ihm ein Mann, den ich auch sehr gut gekannt habe. Es war ein Bekannter von unserer Stadt, der mit neun (9) Kindern gestanden ist. Der Älteste war elf (11) Jahre. Und seine Frau ist auch geblieben dort in der Stadt, wo meine Mutti gearbeitet hat, es sind meistens dort die Frauen gewesen. Und er ist dort...
David Boder: Was war das dort, eine Fabrik?
Fela Nichthauser: Ein Shop hat es geheißen.
David Boder: Und ja was...
Fela Nichthauser: Dort hat man für die Deutschen genäht. Die Uniformen oder die Brotsäcke, und so weiter für die Soldaten.
David Boder: Ja, nun?
Fela Nichthauser: Er stand mit die neun (9) Kinder und es war wirklich...
David Boder: Wie viele Kinder?
Fela Nichthauser: Neun (9).
David Boder: Neun (9)?
Fela Nichthauser: Neun (9) Kinder
David Boder: Ihr Onkel mit neun (9) Kindern?
Fela Nichthauser: Nein, der Mann mit neun (9) Kindern. Das Älteste war elf (11) Jahre alt. Und jeglicher Mann hat zugeschaut, das harteste Herz musste rühren und alle neun (9) Kinder haben angefangen zu weinen und schrecklich, schreckliche Gesichtszüge machen und wirklich...
David Boder: Ja.
Fela Nichthauser: . . . ich finde keine Worte.
David Boder: Nun also hat man ihren Onkel zusammen mit den drei (3) Kindern weg geschickt?
Fela Nichthauser: Weg geschickt, er soll mit den alten Leuten nach Auschwitz.
David Boder: So man hat die Kinder mit den alten Leuten weg geschickt?
Fela Nichthauser: Zusammen,...denn man hat gewusst von den Kindern kann man nichts haben und von den alten Leuten auch nichts haben.
David Boder: Und nun erzählen Sie mir, was hat Ihnen und Ihren Brüdern passiert?
Fela Nichthauser: Wir sind noch auf dem Platz geblieben einige Stunden. Wir haben Essen bekommen und dann haben wir uns gesorgt um die Mutti. Wir haben noch immer geglaubt, dass sie noch jede Weile kommt, aber wir haben leider nicht gewusst, dass in derselben Stadt das Gleiche passiert wie hier.
David Boder: Auch in der anderen Stadt?
Fela Nichthauser: Auch in der anderen Stadt—da hat man auch die Leute ausgesucht. Und obwohl meine Mutti nur fünf und vierzig (45) Jahre gehabt und meine Tanten auch und meine Bekannten, hat man sie doch auch in Aussiedlung genommen und nach Auschwitz geschickt. So wollte es das Schicksal.
David Boder: Ja also, man hat die nach Auschwitz geschickt?
Fela Nichthauser: Ja.
David Boder: Und was war, was war Auschwitz? Auschwitz war ein Arbeitslager?
Fela Nichthauser: Das war ein Arbeitslager. Es hat geheißen Arbeitslager, aber es war doch ein Krematorium. Ich war dort nicht, aber ich kann...die Leute, die persönlich das erlebt haben, haben mir Vieles erzählt.
David Boder: Ja also...
Fela Nichthauser: Und...
David Boder: Und denselben Tag, wo Sie genommen wurden, hat man ihre Mutter von der Arbeit genommen?
Fela Nichthauser: Genommen und nach Auschwitz geschickt mit einem ganzen Transport. Ich habe...man hat mir dann im Lager geschrieben, dass man meine Mutti noch in dem letzten Moment gesehen hat, wo sie in einem Wagon gesessen hat, wo man früher die, hm, die Tiere geführt hat...transportiert hat. Und sie hat noch grüßen lassen alle drei Kinder. Und man hat ihr gesagt, sie soll sich nicht kümmern, die drei Kinder sind ins Lager genommen worden. Und das war das Letzte.
David Boder: Na, warten Sie mal. Ihre Mutter hat dort in der Nacht gearbeitet, ja?
Fela Nichthauser: Ja.
David Boder: Und man hat Sie heraus gerufen am Morgen und Sie dachten, dass Ihre Mutter zurück kommt. Um wie viel Uhr ist Ihre Mutter gewöhnlich zurück gekommen?
Fela Nichthauser: Um halb sechs früh.
David Boder: Und diesmal ist sie nicht gekommen?
Fela Nichthauser: Nein.
David Boder: Aha und das hat dort passiert.
Fela Nichthauser: Ja.
David Boder: Also so sind Sie mit ihrem zwei (2) Brüdern ins Lager?
Fela Nichthauser: Nein, nicht zuerst ins Lager. Zuerst sind wir gegangen nach Sosnovicz. Die Transporte, die ins Lager kamen...
David Boder: Wo Sosnoviczi?
Fela Nichthauser: Ja....waren erst in einem Durchgangslager. Dort wurden die Leute sortiert.
David Boder: Ja.
Fela Nichthauser: Und später hat man die Mädels extra geschickt in ein Frauenlager und die Jungs in die Männerlager.
David Boder: Ja. Und wie alt waren die zwei (2) Jungen?
Fela Nichthauser: Ein Bruder war damals achtzehn (18) und der jüngste Bruder war dreizehn (13) Jahre.
David Boder: Ja. Nun?
Fela Nichthauser: Und da kamen wir...da standen wir vor dem Arzt. Ich war die Erste und er hat gesehen, dass ich gesund bin. Ich war sehr schön...hm, sehr schön abgebrennt, weil ich habe im Feld ein halbes ( ½ ) Jahr gearbeitet für die Deutschen auf dem Feld den ganzen Tag. Und da hat er gesagt, dass ich kann in das Lager kommen. Ich habe damals kein Wort gesagt, denn ich konnte mich nicht wehren. Ich war einverstanden und es hat mir das Herz weh getan. Ich wollte gerne, dass die Brüder, die beiden Brüder nach Hause kommen, denn ich war sicher, dass die Mutti nach Hause doch kommt. Ich habe ja nicht gewusst, dass das Selbe in der anderen Stadt passiert ist. Das haben wir erst später erfahren.
David Boder: Ja.
Fela Nichthauser: Und da steht der ältere Bruder, der achtzehn (18) jährige Bruder vor dem Arzt und der Arzt hat ihn erkannt. Er hat ihn noch...vor zwei (2) Wochen hat er ihn frei gelassen. Da hat er ihn erkannt, das war ein polnischer Arzt und hat ihn gefragt: „Was machen Sie wieder hier? Ich habe dich doch frei gelassen!“ Da sagt er: „Na, was soll ich machen? Es war bei uns eine Aussiedlung und ich muss wieder—ich hab noch den Fuß nicht ganz in Ordnung.“ Sagt er—ohne einen Grund hat er gesagt: „Ich schreib Dir auf, Sie kommen nach Hause zurück.“ Das war das größte Glück. Also er kam nach Hause...er kam an die Seite, zu den Menschen, die nach Hause gekommen seid...sind. Und dann kam vor den Arzt der Kleine und ich hab ihn gebeten, er soll den Kleinen frei lassen, denn er hat noch nicht ganze vierzehn (14) Jahre, er hat dreizehn (13) Jahre geendet. Man soll ihn nach Hause auch lassen, er soll mit der Mutti und mit dem anderen Bruder sein, er ist noch ein Kind und wird nicht so schaffen können. Da hat der Arzt gesagt: „Wenn ich einen frei gelassen hab, kann ich den Anderen nicht.“ Wir haben müssen einverstanden sein, da der Lager Inspektor Knoll, ein deutscher Mann, ein SS Mann, hat alle Juden auf den Platz gerufen, damit er kann sie sehen und in das Lager dirigieren kann. Und dann hat er meinem Bruder damals gesagt, er soll ganz vorne stehen, denn er war klein...
David Boder: Er war klein...
Fela Nichthauser: . . . , zum Kleinen, vielleicht wird ein Glück wieder sein, dass dass das SS Mann doch ein bisschen Herz hat und wenn es um ein Kind geht, vielleicht wird er ihn frei lassen. Er hat so schöne Haare gehabt, goldi...goldene Locken und...er hat ihm doch nicht gefolgt, es war für ihn so etwas Neues, so wie—er kommt ins Lager, es war für ihn ein neues Leben. Er hat es nicht verstanden, was es bedeutet.
David Boder: Hat er geglaubt, es war etwas Gutes?
Fela Nichthauser: Er hat gedacht es war etwas Gutes; er konnte es nicht begreifen, er war doch ein Kind! Und er wollte sich damit wichtig machen, dass er vom Lager Briefe schreiben und so weiter. Man konnte ihm das nicht so gut erklären und doch ist alles bestimmt so beschieden worden, dass der Knoll hat ihn bemerkt, hat ihn nach vorne gerufen zu sich, hat ihn gefragt, wie alt er ist. Und da hat er ihm gesagt dreizehn (13) Jahre. Und hat ihm gefragt, ob er arbeiten kann. Und er hat gesagt: „Ja.“ Ob er ins Lager fahren will, dann hat er gesagt nein. Da hat er gewusst—für sich alleine kann er sagen das Ja. Dann hat er ihn gefragt, ob er Jemanden zu Hause hat...
David Boder: Ja.
Fela Nichthauser: . . . da sagt er: „Ich habe die Mutti zu Hause“. Er hat geglaubt, dass die Mutti zu Hause ist.
David Boder: Also was hat der Knoll gesagt?
Fela Nichthauser: Er hat ihn gefragt, ob er Jemanden zu Hause hat und er hat gesagt; „Ja, ich habe die Mutti.“ Also hat er gemacht „Los, nach Hause.“ Und ich stand im Fenster und habe alles das gesehen, alles gehört und es war wieder ein Glück, dass man durch einen wirklich reinen Zufall den Kleinen, meinen kleinen Bruder frei gelassen hat. Und so sind die zwei (2) wieder nach Hause zurück gekommen und ich bin ins Lager genommen worden.
David Boder: Ja, nun was hat dann passiert?
Fela Nichthauser: Und...ich...
David Boder: Nach welchem Lager wurden Sie genommen?
Fela Nichthauser: Ich wurde genommen nach Birken...nach Birkenheim. Das war der Kreis (Name unverständlich) in Nieder Schlesien.
David Boder: Ja.
Fela Nichthauser: Dort war eine ganz große Fabrik, eine Weberei.
David Boder: Ja, hm, wo war die Fabrik?
Fela Nichthauser: In Birkenheim. Und eine ganz große Fabrik, wo die Deutschen gearbeitet haben und wo schon hundert (100) Mädels waren in den Baracken und sind dann noch hundert gekommen von unserer Stadt und von verschiedenen Städten auch.
David Boder: Ja.
Fela Nichthauser: Und so habe ich das erste Mal gefühlt, dass hinter mich ist alles verloren. Das Tor hat sich zu gemacht und ich kam in einen dunklen Saal, wo nur Betten, Betten und noch einmal Betten standen und sonst nichts mehr. Und so hat sich angefangen mein zweites (2.) Leben.
David Boder: Ja, nun? Und das war wo?
Fela Nichthauser: In Birkenheim. Dort war ich ein halbes ( ½ ) Jahr. Dort habe ich schwer gearbeitet als Weberin.
David Boder: An einem Webstuhl?
Fela Nichthauser: An einen, zwei Webstühle.
David Boder: Aha. Waren das elektrische Webstühle?
Fela Nichthauser: Ja, elektrische Webstühle, ich habe müssen selbst bei der Maschine, hm, hm,...alles gewebt, alles alleine abgenommen, habe wieder frisches Material gegeben, habe [unverständlich]. Das hat mir der deutsche Meister alles gelernt.
David Boder: Ja.
Fela Nichthauser: Und es war nicht sehr schlimm mit dem Essen und mit der Sauberkeit, nur schrecklich wenig Freiheit. Wir haben überhaupt keine Menschen gesehen. Das Tor war mit dicke...hm, und mit Reissecken hm,...
David Boder: Zugemacht. Mit was? Mit Säcken und was noch?
Fela Nichthauser: Mit Reissecken.
David Boder: Mit einem Nagel, mit Nägel?
Fela Nichthauser: Mit Nägel.
David Boder: Ja.
Fela Nichthauser: . . . damit wir nicht die Strasse sehen. Wir haben nichts gesehen, nur ein Stückchen Garten, wo wir gesessen haben und die Baracke.
David Boder: Hat man Ihnen irgendwelche Zeitungen und Bücher erlaubt?
Fela Nichthauser: Nein, absolut nicht - wir durften einmal alle zwei Wochen schreiben einen Brief, eine Karte, das war alles. Und am Sonntag, wo wir frei hatten, durften wir auf dem Bett liegen oder auf das Stückchen Platz gehen, wo wir uns, wo wir kaum Platz hatten für uns und nicht mehr.
David Boder: Und durften Sie singen, durften Sie...(beide sprechen)?
Fela Nichthauser: Ja, das durften wir, das war das erste Jahr des Lagers, da war es noch nicht so schlimm. Es war noch kein Konzentrationslager, es war ein sogenanntes Arbeitslager, wo man sehr streng arbeitet und im Winter durfte man sich nicht anziehen...
David Boder: Warum nicht?
Fela Nichthauser: Zum Beispiel, nur zur Fabrik. Und in der Fabrik durfte man nicht in einem Pullover oder einer Jacke arbeiten, man musste ganz frei sein, denn man hat Angst gehabt, dass man schlecht arbeitet, wenn man sich so warm anzieht, man hat wenig Bewegungen und hat geglaubt, dass man macht weniger Meter Stoff, wenn man sich langsamer bewegt. Wenn man leicht angezogen ist, dann kann man sich doch schneller, hm, da...
David Boder: Bewegen.
Fela Nichthauser: . . . bewegen.
David Boder: War die Fabrik geheizt, dass man...?
Fela Nichthauser: Nein, überhaupt nicht geheizt. Es waren ganz große, schrecklich große Säle wo nur Maschinen und Maschinen gestanden haben. Und wir konnten, wir durften den ganzen Tag nicht sprechen, auch nicht einmal zueinander, denn die Mädels sind nebeneinander gestanden., weil die...das Motor, also die verschiedenen Motoren von den Maschinen haben es nicht erlaubt.
David Boder: War es zu...zu Geräusch...ein zu großes Geräusch?
Fela Nichthauser: Ja. Und man hat uns speziell vor den Augen eine ganz große Uhr gegeben damit wir sehen, wie spät es ist, damit wir wissen, dass wir von sieben (7) bis zwölf (12) arbeiten müssen und von eins bis sechs (6) abends. Und es soll die Zeit längern, denn wenn man hat eine Uhr vor sich, dann geht doch die Zeit viel langsamer, wenn man die Stunden nicht sieht, dann fragt man „Wie spät? Wie spät?“, also man hat dann eine Überraschung, wenn man sagt, es ist schon elf (11) oder halb zwölf, als wenn man andauernd die Stunden hat, ist doch sehr schlecht. Und sie haben das extra gemacht, damit wir uns eben schlechter fühlen.
David Boder: Ja. Nun sagen Sie mal, was hat passiert, wenn jemand krank war?
Fela Nichthauser: Wenn jemand krank war, dann musste er schon wirklich krank sein und dann konnte er in dem Lager einen Tag oder zwei (2) Tage bleiben.
David Boder: Hm, und war da ein Arzt? War da ein Hospital?
Fela Nichthauser: Nein, absolut nicht. Es war nur eine Pflegerin und eine ganz kleine Krankenstube von zwei (2) oder drei (3) Betten. Und wenn jemand wirklich Gallensteine hatte oder mit dem Herz zu tun hatte, hat man ihn hin gelegt auf einige Tage, bis er wieder so...so gesund war, dass er wieder arbeiten konnte.
David Boder: Und nun sagen Sie mir dies, das hat wie lange gedauert in der Weberei?
Fela Nichthauser: Sechs Monate haben wir dort gearbeitet und dann ist ein Befehl gekommen, dass, hm, in einem anderen Lager, das heißt Waldenburg, das ist auch in Nieder Schlesien, da braucht man 50 Mädels.
David Boder: Ah hm.
Fela Nichthauser: Und so hat man uns geteilt, ich war auch in dem Teil der Gruppe, die weg gefahren ist.
David Boder: Ja.
Fela Nichthauser: So habe ich das Lager verlassen und bin in das andere Lager gekommen, das war nicht eine Weberei, das war eine Spinnerei.
David Boder: Eine Spinnerei?
Fela Nichthauser: Eine Spinnerei.
David Boder: Nun haben Sie das von Neuem lernen müssen?
Fela Nichthauser: Von dort war noch kein Mensch. Es war ein neues Lager, man hat nur die Baracken aufgestellt. Und es war nichts. Nur Betten drinnen, sonst nichts mehr. Wir mussten um alles bitten. Man wollte uns kein Wasser geben und keine Schüssel. Man hat geglaubt, weil wir Juden sind, brauchen wir nichts. Wir halten...wir halten uns schmutzig und wir brauchen gar nichts. Wir können leben wie Tiere. So haben wir müssen kämpfen um jede Schüssel, um jedes [unverständlich], um jede Decke zum Zudecken. Schon nach einigen Monaten hatte sich die Sache geregelt bis die Lagerführerin gekommen ist und sie hat uns dann ein bisserl verstanden, denn sie hat gesehen gesunde und intelligente Menschen mit denen man sprechen kann. Und da hat sie dann doch gewusst, dass das eben so ist, wie man davon in er Fabrik spricht. Und da hat sie mit dem Direktor gesprochen und hat uns verschiedene Sachen gegeben.
David Boder: Wer war der Lagerführer?
Fela Nichthauser: Sie war eine deutsche Frau, keine SS Frau, sie war nur eine deutsche Frau.
David Boder: Nun hat es manchmal passiert, dass manche nicht arbeiten wollten oder?
Fela Nichthauser: Nein, Jede wollte arbeiten, denn Jede war gesund. Jede nicht gerne, aber gezwungen sind wir zur Arbeit gegangen und wenn man sie bei der Maschine hingestellt hat, ist sie schon geblieben und hat gearbeitet.
David Boder: Ja.
Fela Nichthauser: Und mit der Zeit hat man sich an die Arbeit gewöhnt, weil man hat nicht sehr schlechte Leute um sich gehabt. Man hat mit Deutschen zusammen gearbeitet und man konnte von Zeit zu Zeit ein Wort zu ihnen sprechen. Und, hm, dort waren wir achtzehn (18) Monate.
David Boder: Ach Sie meinen, dass da auch Deutsche gearbeitet haben? Waren die Häftlinge oder waren die freie Menschen?
Fela Nichthauser: Freie Menschen, freie Deutsche.
David Boder: Die zur Arbeit gekommen sind?
Fela Nichthauser: Ja, die verdienen wollten.
David Boder: Waren die freundlich zu den Häftlingen?
Fela Nichthauser: Nicht alle. Manche waren gefährlich. Manche haben aufgepasst speziell, ob wir mit den anderen Deutschen sprechen.
David Boder: Ja.
Fela Nichthauser: Man musste sehr vorsichtig sein.
David Boder: Nun und wie lange hat das gedauert?
Fela Nichthauser: Achtzehn (18) Monate war ich dort.
David Boder: Hat man Ihnen was gezahlt für die Arbeit?
Fela Nichthauser: Nein, absolut nicht.
David Boder: Gab es da nicht ein Lager-Geld? Scheine für die Kantine und so?
Fela Nichthauser: Nein, absolut nicht. Wir haben eigene Küche gehabt.
David Boder: Ja.
Fela Nichthauser: Und unsere Mädels haben in der Küche gekocht.
David Boder: Ja, hat man Ihnen Seife gegeben?
Fela Nichthauser: Nein absolut nicht. Wir haben noch von dem anderen Lager gehabt. Wir sind doch ins Lager gekommen und haben noch von zu Hause die ganzen Sachen gehabt. Und wir haben Seife gehabt und das alles was man braucht. Und das hat man uns doch...nie...nicht weg genommen, so dass uns das alles geblieben ist.
David Boder: Aha, nun und so waren sie anderthalb (1 ½ ) Jahre in der Spinnerei.
Fela Nichthauser: Ja, anderthalb (1 ½ ) in der Spinnerei.
David Boder: Und das war in welcher Stadt?
Fela Nichthauser: In Waldenburg.
David Boder: In Waldenburg. Und wo sind Sie von Waldenburg gegangen?
Fela Nichthauser: Von Waldenburg bin ich gegangen dann nach Graeben. Das ist zwölf Kilometer von einem ganz großen und ganz berühmten Lager...Groß-Rosen.
David Boder: Ja und warum hat man Sie von Waldenburg weggeschickt?
Fela Nichthauser: Weil es ist damals die Zeit gekommen, wo man alle kleinen Lager konzentriert hat in eine grössere Lager. Und unser Lager hat...ist gewesen nur fünfzig Leute und da ist eben gekommen der Knoll, der Selbe, der einmal in Sosnowicz war. Er ist zu uns gekommen und hat gesagt, wir müssen in ein anderes Lager fahren.
David Boder: Ja. Und?
Fela Nichthauser: Und wir haben das eines Tages verlassen das Lager und sind dann gefahren nach Graeben, das war eine Flachserei.
David Boder: Nur Frauen?
Fela Nichthauser: Nur Frauen, ja natürlich, das war nur ein Frauenlager und dort sind wir gewesen wieder ein...anderthalb (1 ½ ) Jahre wieder. Aber dort haben schon angefangen schlimme Zeiten. Das war dann ein Konzentrationslager, wo ganz streng alles war, wo haben wir absolut gespürt, dass wir keine Menschen sind. Keine Juden sind, sondern nur Tiere, die hängen wirklich ab von den Deutschen.
David Boder: Das war in der Flachserei?
Fela Nichthauser: In der Flachserei. (man hört andere Stimmen auf dem Tonband, sehr leise—Dr. Boder scheint mit Jemandem zu sprechen). Die Arbeit war sehr schwer, ich habe sehr gelitten. Es waren wieder große Säle und wir haben den ganzen Winter gearbeitet. Es war schrecklich kalt, wir hatten nicht zum Anziehen, man hat uns alles weg genommen. Die SS ist eines Tages zu uns gekommen, viele Männer und viele Frauen; und haben uns...haben uns aus dem Bett raus gezogen...
David Boder: Ja.
Fela Nichthauser: Man hat uns gesagt, wir sollen aus den Betten aufstehen und wir sollen auf den Platz auf dem Hof gehen. Und dann hat man uns gezählt und man hat zu uns gesprochen und einer der SS Männer hat zu uns gesagt, dass er sieht, dass wir so gesund und schön sind und es wird uns hier nicht schlecht sein, man lässt uns alle Sachen, die wir hier haben, wir hatten noch von zu Hause diese alle Sachen. Und wir sollen gut arbeiten und es wird uns nicht schlecht sein.
David Boder: In demselben Platz—in der Flachserei?
Fela Nichthauser: In demselben Platz, ja. Und da haben sie uns gesagt, wir sollen eine Stunde draußen bleiben. Wir sind eine Stunde draußen geblieben.
David Boder: In welchem Monat war das?
Fela Nichthauser: Das war im Sommer, in welchem Monat weiß ich nicht.
David Boder: Ja, das macht nichts. Ja?
Fela Nichthauser: Das war im vier und vierziger (44) Jahr im Sommer.
David Boder: Ja?
Fela Nichthauser: Und sie haben gesagt wir sollen alle draußen bleiben. Und dann sind sie gegangen in die Baracken—alle SS Frauen und alle SS Männer in das Lager, in die Baracken und haben uns alles, hm, hm, weg genommen und...zerstört alles.
David Boder: Was meinen Sie mit ‚sie haben alles zerstört’?
Fela Nichthauser: Sie haben alle Schränke aufgemacht und die ganzen Betten durch gesucht und eine Revidierung gemacht, was wir haben und die schönsten Sachen und die ärgsten Sachen, die hat man so durcheinander geschmissen und, und mit der Schere geschnitten. Ganz...alles zerstört.
David Boder: Und dann?
Fela Nichthauser: Und wir haben doch nichts davon gewusst. Man hat uns doch vor einer Weile gesagt, dass wir es gut werden haben und dann man alle Sachen lässt und wir werden können uns anziehen, wie wir wollen und so weiter. Und das war nur ein Trick von ihnen, damit wir auf eine Weile vergessen und inzwischen haben sie uns so eine Unordnung gemacht.
David Boder: [In English] This concludes Spool fifteen (15) of Fela Nichthauser and we shall continue with her story on Spool sixteen (16). David Boder, Interviewer.
David Boder: This is a continuation of Spool 15—Spool 16 , the continuation of the story of Fela Nichthauser.
David Boder: [In German] Nun, Fela, Sie haben gesagt, die SS sind gekommen und man hat Ihnen geheißen, dass Sie draußen bleiben werden, man hat Ihnen versprochen, dass Sie Ihre Sachen behalten werden und dann sind die herein gegangen in die Baracken, weil Sie draußen waren und was haben die getan?
Fela Nichthauser: Sie haben unsere Sachen gründlich, gründlich zerstört.
David Boder: Ja.
Fela Nichthauser: Und dann haben sie uns gesagt, wir sollen herein gehen. Und wir haben nichts gehabt zum Anziehen, absolut nichts, außer das was wir angehabt haben. Und es sind viele Mädels gewesen, die gerade zum Baden vorbereitet waren und so hatten sie nur das auf dem Leib einen Morgenrock, den sie drüber geworfen haben und das Andere haben sie in der Stube gelassen, in den Baracken. Und so sind sie auch ganz nackt nur in dem Morgenrock geblieben.
David Boder: Na, was heißt das, sie haben die Sachen zerstört?
Fela Nichthauser: Weil sie wollten doch nicht, dass wir in die schönen Sachen herum gehen, wir waren doch jung und Mädels und wir hatten doch die ganzen Sachen noch von zu Hause. Sie wollten nicht. Sie wollten doch nur das, dass sie damit die Satisfaktion haben, dass sie unsere ganzen Sachen kaputt gemacht haben.
David Boder: Ja, aber was haben sie mit den Sachen getan, sagen Sie mir die Einzelheiten.
Fela Nichthauser: Die haben...die meisten Sachen haben sie ausgewählt da und da haben sie ein Magazin gemacht und haben gesagt, wir werden jede Woche bekommen ein Hemd, ein Paar Schlüpfer, ein Kleid oder einen Mantel, wenn es wird kalt sein; und so, mussten wir natürlich damit einverstanden sein. Und wir durften nichts haben. Und dann, nachher haben wir wieder die ganzen Stuben in Ordnung gebracht und da haben sie gesagt, es soll sich keine von uns wagen, mehr, wie ein paar Strümpfe zu haben oder mehr wie ein paar Schlüpfer haben oder ein Hemd...
David Boder: Was ist ein Schlüpfer?
Fela Nichthauser: Schlüpfer...Hosen.
David Boder: Ja.
Fela Nichthauser: Wir sollen uns nicht wagen mehr zu haben, als das was sie uns geben werden. Und das war für uns ein sehr großer Schlag, denn wir sind nicht das gewohnt haben...wir sind nicht dazu gewohnt gewesen. Und jede Sache, die man noch von zu Hause hatte, war für uns sehr teuer, denn man hat uns an alles erinnert. Und es ist sehr schwer gekommen im Krieg etwas zu machen. Und doch sie haben uns das alles so ohne...so ohne, hm, und ohne nichts so ganz zerstört. Und sie wollten es sehen. Dann haben sie uns gesagt, wir sollen weiter arbeiten—wir waren nach der Nachtschicht, nichts gegessen, nicht geschlafen und nicht gewaschen und sie haben uns gesagt, wir sollen in die Fabrik gehen und weiter, wie gewöhnlich arbeiten.
Fela Nichthauser: Und es kam Winter, ein sehr starker und schlimmer Winter. Und wir mussten bei den Maschinen stehen, die tausendmal so gross waren, wie wir alleine. Schrecklich gross, ohne eine Hilfe, ohne Niemanden, in Frost und mit Hunger haben wir müssen dort stehen und arbeiten zwölf Stunden, von sechs (6) früh bis sechs (6) abends eine Woche und die nächste Woche von sechs (6) abends bis sechs (6) früh mit einer Viertel ( ¼ ) Stunde Pause.
David Boder: Und Sonntag hat man gearbeitet?
Fela Nichthauser: Sonntag hat man meistens gearbeitet. Es hat geheißen wir haben frei, aber dann ist gekommen der Wagen mit dem Flachs aus dem Feld und da mussten wir alle zur Arbeit gehen und dies alles abladen...auch im größten kalten Winter.
David Boder: Und was haben Sie mit dem Flachs getan...in, an der Maschine?
Fela Nichthauser: Die Maschine haben das durcharbeitet und das...das kam ein besserer Flachs schon und dann ist das noch durch alle...durch andere Maschinen ge...hm, ge...
David Boder: Gegangen.
Fela Nichthauser: . . . gegangen, ja, und dann ist das in die Spinnerei gekommen.
David Boder: Aha.
Fela Nichthauser: Und dann von der Spinnerei in die Weberei gegangen.
David Boder: Ja. Nun und wie lange waren Sie in dieser Flachserei?
Fela Nichthauser: Anderthalb (1 ½ ) Jahre.
David Boder: Anderthalb (1 ½ ) Jahre. Und...(beide sprechen)
Fela Nichthauser: Und dort war ich wirklich krank auch. Ich bin einmal vom Bett herunter gefallen, weil wir hatten zwei (2) stöckige, drei (3) stöckige Betten. Und ich war nach der Nachtschicht und ich wollte früh aufstehen und ich war noch ganz verschlafen gewesen und da bin ich herunter gefallen und ich da habe ich mich auf dem Knochen ein bisschen, eine ganz kleine Wunde gemacht. Und ich habe es nicht beobachtet, ich habe geglaubt, es wir verheilt werden in zwei (2) Tagen. Dann aber ich habe im Staub gearbeitet, es war schrecklich verstaubt—das war eigentlich das Schlimmste für uns—weil der Staub ist uns auf die Nase und die Lungen gegangen. Wir konnten nicht sprechen und nicht atmen, weil wir haben nicht einmal Eine die Andere gesehen, weil so viel Staub war. Und dann ist der Staub auch in die kleine Wunde gekommen und da hat sich das vergrößert.
David Boder: [In English] She shows now a wound on her right leg, hm, a scar rather of two inches long and one (1) and one half ( ½ ) inch wide which was the result of an infection of a little wound that she made, when she fell out of bed when in a drowsy fashion and she tried to get up in the morning.
David Boder: [In German] Also.
Fela Nichthauser: Und die Wunde hat sich von Tag zu Tag vergrößert und es ist Eiter gekommen und ich habe vierzig (40) Fieber bekommen und dann musste ich im Bett liegen. Ich habe geglaubt, dass es in einer Woche, zwei (2) Wochen vorbei gehen; und doch es hat gedauert zwei ein halb (2 ½ ) Monate. Ich konnte herum gehen, ich war ganz schwach und so bin ich geblieben im Bett zwei ein halb (2 ½ ) Monate. Und dann, hm,...
David Boder: Sind Sie in der Baracke geblieben?
Fela Nichthauser: In der Baracke geblieben.
David Boder: Sie waren nicht im Hospital?
Fela Nichthauser: Nein, absolut nicht.
David Boder: Ist der Doktor gekommen, um Sie zu sehen?
Fela Nichthauser: Nein, absolut nicht. Es ist noch...ich wollte nicht, denn...wenn ich möchte den Doktor verlangen, dann kommt der deutsche Arzt und er wird sagen, dass ich muss nach Auschwitz kommen, weil ich bin unfähig zu arbeiten. Und so ist es auch gewesen nach einer Zeit.
David Boder: Und wie hat man Ihnen denn erlaubt zu stehen im Bett, wenn am Morgen beim Appell, wenn man Ihren Namen gerufen hat.
Fela Nichthauser: Ja, da hat die Ärztin, die war bei uns—eine Sanitäterin, eine russische Sanitäterin—hat sie gesagt, dass die Nichthauser, die ist krank, die kann nicht arbeiten und man hat es für wahr angenommen. Und übrigens, die Lagerführerin, eine SS Lager Führerin ist jeden Tag durch alle Stuben gegangen und hat geguckt, ob Eine nicht geblieben ist oder in die Krankenstube ist - sie ist herein gekommen und hat geguckt, ob nicht Eine extra krank macht oder sonst was und sie hat selbst untersucht die Leute. Und dann...
David Boder: Und sie hat selbst untersucht?
Fela Nichthauser: . . . und dann...alle Meldungen von unserem Lager sind gegangen nach Groß-Rosen, weil das war nicht weit.
David Boder: Was heißt die Meldungen?
Fela Nichthauser: Zum Beispiel, wir haben gehört, gehört...zugehört zu dem Lager Groß-Rosen und...
David Boder: Ja.
Fela Nichthauser: . . . und alles was ist geschehen in unserem Lager hier, davon musste die Kommandantur in Groß-Rosen wissen. Nun, zum Beispiel, es ist jeden Tag gegangen eine Liste von den Kranken und auch von den Gesunden, die zur Arbeit gegangen sind. Und so ist mein Name auch dorthin gegangen fast jeden Tag, dass ich krank bin die zwei ein halb (2 ½ ) Monate—ständig krank. Und das hat ihnen wahrscheinlich nicht sehr gefallen, dass ich so lange im Lager bleib und da hat man einen Befehl gegeben, dass man mich nach Auschwitz schicken muss, in das Krematorium, weil ich unfähig bin zu arbeiten; man kann mich nicht länger halten.
David Boder: Nun?
Fela Nichthauser: Mir hat man das nicht gesagt, denn sie haben gekannt meine empfindliche Natur und man hat Angst gehabt, ich werd irgend was machen. So hat man mir das nicht gesagt, das hat man mir erst nach der Freiheit gesagt, dass ich sollte damals...in ein paar Tagen sollte ich nach Auschwitz gehen und alle waren schrecklich traurig, aber man konnte doch nichts machen und es wäre bestimmt so gewesen, wenn nicht eines Tages kam der Befehl, dass alle Mädchen, das ganze Lager also, müssen auf einen Transport gehen.
Fela Nichthauser: Das ist einmal wieder die Zeit gewesen, wo alle Lager wurden ge..., hm, gelöst und man hat alle gejagt, weil die Russen waren schon da.
David Boder: Nun?
Fela Nichthauser: Und da haben wir müssen—die Kranken—auch aufstehen und die Gesunden alle die ganzen Sachen packen, alles was wir hatten. Und wir haben ein Stückchen Brot bekommen, ein Stückchen Margarine und Marmelade und so sind wir gegangen zu Fuß auf den Transport., Man hat nicht gewusst wo und wie; wir sind gegangen fünf und dreißig (35) Kilometer täglich—ohne Aufhören, ohne Pause, ohne nichts...und SS Männer mit Soldaten, mit die ganzen SS Frauen, die mit uns gewesen sind und so hat man uns gejagt Tag und Nacht. Und in der Nacht haben...
David Boder: Die SS Leute sind auch zu Fuß gegangen?
Fela Nichthauser: Ja, auch zu Fuß gegangen, ja. Es ist oftmals passiert, dass ein Auto vorbei gefahren ist und da hat man alle SS Männer genommen auf das Auto. Nur zwei (2) oder drei (3) Soldaten hat man bei uns gelassen, damit sie uns bewachen, ja. Und die allen Anderen sind, hm, sind einige Kilometer, hm,...
David Boder: Nach vorne gefahren.
Fela Nichthauser: . . . nach vorne gefahren, ja, und dann haben sie wieder auf uns gewartet auch in einer Stadt.
David Boder: Nun und haben alle gehen können?
Fela Nichthauser: Man konnte nicht gehen eben, ich konnte selbst nicht gehen. Ja, ich habe eine kranken Fuß und ich habe vierzig (40) Fieber gehabt damals, neun und dreißig...ich hab damals auch...(unverständlich—beide sprechen)
David Boder: War es Winter oder Sommer?
Fela Nichthauser: Das war im Winter, es war im Januar.
David Boder: Im Januar, ja.
Fela Nichthauser: Im Januar und bevor wir noch herausgegangen sind—wir haben gewusst, dass wir eines Tages lange gehen werden, haben die Mädels von diese Bettdecken Strümpfe genäht und Mützen genäht...
David Boder: Hat man das erlaubt?
Fela Nichthauser: Man hat nicht erlaubt. Man hat das...man hat das versteckt eben. Die hätte uns natürlich...die hätten uns tot geschlagen, wenn sie gewusst hat, dass man das genäht hat. Dann, wenn sie hat gesehen bei dem Tag von dem Transport, dass wir das alles an haben, hat sie es schon nicht gesagt, weil da hat es ja schon nicht dran gelegen, denn sie hat sowieso das Lager verlassen. Und das hat uns eben ein bisschen gerettet, denn es war schrecklich kalt und draußen haben wir, zum Beispiel, eine Nacht sind wir hinein in ein Dorf gekommen, wo man hat uns erlaubt in einer Scheune zu schlafen. Und wir waren doch fünf hundert (500) Mädels und es konnten doch kaum hundert fünfzig herein gehen und das Übrige ist draußen geblieben. Da haben wir uns so auf die Steine auf den Schnee hin gelegt. Es ist nur ein Wunder, dass Viele nicht für immer eingeschlafen haben. Und so sind wir gegangen, gegangen...bis wir kamen nach Yanoff. Ich weiß nicht, wo das ist, ich kenne nur den Namen von der Stadt. Und dort hat man uns auf die Wagen gegeben,...
David Boder: Welche? Eisenbahnwagen?
Fela Nichthauser: Ja, Eisenbahnwagen, aber solche Kohlenwagen...
David Boder: Offene Wagen.
Fela Nichthauser: Offene Wagen,...so schmutzig und wo konnten nur achtzig (80) Personen herein gehen, da hat man hundert fünfzig (150) hinein gegeben. Und man hat Eine auf der Anderen gelegen, man hat geschrien und wir haben angefangen schon keine Menschen zu werden, weil wir haben gewusst, es geht nicht anders. Man musste sagen: „Rück Dich ein bisserl“ Oder „Mach Platz“ oder man musste irgend ein scharfes Wort sagen, alles ging nicht anders. Sie haben das extra so gemacht, damit wir uns gegen einander schlecht sind, damit wir uns streiten, damit wir uns schlagen...hm, geschlagen haben wir uns nicht, aber es hat auch nicht zu viel dazu...hm,...
David Boder: Gefehlt.
Fela Nichthauser: . . . gefehlt, weil es waren schrecklich Verhältnisse. Überhaupt nichts gegessen und Tag und Nacht gefahren mit den Wagen, es hat geschneit und wir waren durch und durch nass und die SS Männer und die Soldaten, die hatten einen extra Wagen, nicht einen Personenwagen, aber einen...der auch...einen gedeckten Wagen und dort haben sie einen, hm, einen - nicht einen elektrischen Ofen—nur einen Ofen gehabt und dort haben sie sich gekocht und gemacht alles und warmen Kaffee getrunken und wir haben müssen da zugucken. So sind wir einige Tage gefahren. Und dann haben wir auf einer Station sich angestellt, wollten wir...haben wir sie gebeten die Lagerführerin soll uns erlauben sich waschen, denn wir waren schon zwei (2) oder drei (3) Wochen nicht gewaschen,wir waren doch auf der, hm, auf der Reise zu Fuß. Und da hat sie uns erlaubt—das war im Januar—da haben wir uns ausgezogen und sind in den Teich gegangen und da haben wir im eiskalten Wasser gewaschen und sie hat uns bewundert—alle haben uns bewundert . Man wollte nicht glauben, dass das Juden sind, man hat nur gehört, dass Juden schmutzig sind, sie können sich nicht sauber halten. Und da hat sie gesehen, dass die jungen und schönen Mädels, die haben sich wohl in seinem Wasser. Mit dem Messer haben wir das Eis abgeschlagen, ja, damit wir uns ein bisschen waschen können. Wir haben unsere Sachen geputzt und sind wieder in den schmutzigen Wagon zurück gegangen.
Fela Nichthauser: Und dann sind wir wieder einige Wochen gefahren ohne Essen, ohne nichts. Man hat uns kalte Konserven gegeben, ohne Brot , ohne nichts. Das war gesalzen und kein Wasser. Es war ein...ein großes Wunder, wenn man hat einen Soldaten gebeten, er soll uns von einer, von einem, hm,...
David Boder: Brunnen.
Fela Nichthauser: . . . Brunnen ein bisschen Wasser bringen. Auf jeder Station war so viel Wasser, aber man wollte uns nicht erlauben. Und manches Mal, wenn der Zug ist gestanden, sind wir zu der Lokomotive gegangen und wir haben das schmutzige, warme Ölwasser genommen. Es war so fett vom Öl, das haben wir fast, fast geklaut, so niemand wird uns sehen und wir haben das Wasser, das schmutzige Wasser getrunken. So sind wir eine Nacht nach Belsen gekommen.
David Boder: Ja.
Fela Nichthauser: Und dort sind wir draußen gestanden - um drei (3) Uhr nachts gekommen. Und man hat uns gesagt, wir müssen zuerst baden, weil die haben Angst, dass wir Läuse haben. Und so, - wir sind fünf hundert (500) Mädels gewesen, sie haben uns in fünf (5) Gruppen geteilt und jede Gruppe ist gegangen separat und dann haben sie die Mädels an einem anderen Ausgang aus gelassen, dass sie nicht mit uns sprechen können und nichts uns erzählen, was man da macht, dass wir etwas vorbereitet sind. Und das war eben ganz schlecht, das Schlechte. Und so bin ich auch dran gekommen. Hat man uns ausgezogen, ganz nackt ausgezogen und man durfte nur die Schuhe nehmen...
David Boder: Wer hat das getan? Waren das Frauen?
Fela Nichthauser: Nein, das waren Männer.
David Boder: Und Männer haben Sie ausgezogen?
Fela Nichthauser: Ja, das war speziell, damit wir eben noch niedriger sind, wie wir waren, damit sie die Satisfaktion haben, dass die Männer das machen, mit einem ironischen Lachen. Mit einem, mit einem...(unverständlich—beide sprechen)
David Boder: (unverständlich—beide sprechen)
Fela Nichthauser: Frauen waren auch dabei, jüdische Frauen waren dabei, die mussten es machen.
David Boder: Also was waren die Frauen (unverständlich—beide sprechen)...
Fela Nichthauser: Die Frauen, die haben geholfen, die haben die Sachen weg genommen von uns, die haben sie aufgehängt auf einen Bügel und die Sachen sind gegangen in einen speziellen Ofen, wo man hatte sie desinfiziert, damit keine Läuse dran bleiben, obwohl wir damals keine Läuse hatten.
David Boder: Nun?
Fela Nichthauser: Und die haben uns ausgezogen und haben gesagt, dass wir die Sachen zurück kriegen. Und, hm, sind wir zum Baden gegangen, da wollten wir Hemd nehmen oder Handtuch, da haben sie uns nichts erlaubt nehmen, wir sind so gegangen und nur die Schuhe durfte man nehmen. Und ich war froh damals, ich hatte keine Schuhe, es waren nur ganz große Holzschuhe, wo drei Paar Füße, meine Füße könnten sein in den Schuh herein gehen, mit welchen ich habe schon Monate lang in dem Lager gearbeitet und die durfte man mitnehmen. Ich habe noch Bilder von zu Hause von meiner Mutti, vom Papa, von meinen Geschwistern und viele, viele Bilder, aber ich wollte speziell nur die von meiner Familie nehmen, hat man mir nicht erlaubt. Man hat sofort es verbrannt, ich habe ein paar ganz kleine Bilder gehabt, die habe ich im Schuh versteckt—ganz tief—und so, dass man es nicht gesehen hat. So habe ich die paar Bilder gerettet, die heute für mich einen großen Wert haben. Und so sind wir baden gegangen, es waren auch Männer dabei, die haben sich, hm, gelacht und die haben sich uns Spott, sie sind vorbei gegangen durch die nasse, hm, hm, die nassen Körper und sie haben die...ich kann ich nicht deutsch ausdrücken...und sie haben so gemacht...
David Boder: Sie haben Sie an den Rücken, hm,...
Fela Nichthauser: . . . geklatscht.
David Boder: . . . geklatscht.
Fela Nichthauser: Und wir haben gebadet und sie haben uns genommen in einen Saal, wo das Wasser mit Frost zusammen auf den Wänden war. Und kein Handtuch gegeben, nichts, keine Seife und so haben wir uns abgewaschen mit dem Wasser und in dem Saal sind wir gestanden stundenlang und gewartet bis, bis die Sachen von dem Ofen von der Desinfektion kommen. Und so haben wir von alleine abgetrocknet. Das Wasser auf die Haare sind zu ge...zugefroren auf den Kopf und das Wasser hat auch...diese Tropfen Wasser sind eingefroren und so haben wir uns Einer zu dem Anderen gedrückt, damit es uns etwas wärmer wird. Das wollten wir wirklich nicht glauben, dass man mit uns so machen kann, nach dem heißen Baden, ganz heißes Wasser in so eine kalten Saal nehmen, wo nur Kälte und Frost war und da haben wir von alleine abgetrocknet, ich hab gezittert und war ganz blau von Kälte. So haben wir zwei Stunden gewartet bis die Sachen gekommen sind. Und sind die Sachen doch nicht alle gekommen. Und nicht auch meine; ich habe ein Kleid bekommen von einem anderen Mädel und ein Mädel hat wieder Sachen von mir bekommen. So das war ganz durcheinander. Kaum haben wir ein Hemd, eine Hose und ein Kleid bekommen.
David Boder: Nun?
Fela Nichthauser: Und sonst nichts, alles Andere mussten wir lassen. So sind wir gegangen in der Nacht, spät in der Nacht gegangen in die Baracke. Wir wurden gejagt und geschlagen damit wir schneller gehen.
David Boder: Wer hat Sie geschlagen?
Fela Nichthauser: Die Soldaten. Die waren dort die Soldaten, gewöhnliche Soldaten, nicht SS und wir wussten doch nicht den Weg in die Baracke und es war schrecklich weit von dem, von dem...Badeanstalt. Wir sind...wir kamen zu der Baracke, es war ganz dunkel, man hat überhaupt nicht die Tür gesehen nichts. Da hat man uns so herein gestoßen, wo...wie Schweine, abgesperrt und weg gegangen. Und so in der Dunkelheit haben wir gesucht ein Bett, oder irgend einen Tisch...man konnte nichts finden, aber wir haben geglaubt (unverständlich—Geräusch im Tonband) und wir können es nicht anrühren. Und dann dam nächsten Tag, wo es schon licht...wo es schon hell draußen war, haben wir gesehen, dass wir hier nichts haben, nur den Boden, Wände und aufgeschlagene Scheiben und es hat geweht von allen Seiten. So haben wir uns hin gesetzt auf den schmutzigen Fußboden und dann hat wieder angefangen das Leben.
Fela Nichthauser: Ich war seit Januar bis April war ich in Belsen. Aber die paar Monate haben mir viele, viel, viel mehr gemacht als die drei ein halb (3 ½ )Jahre, was ich war in den anderen Lagern. In den anderen Lagern konnte ich mich noch abwaschen, obwohl ich Hunger gelitten habe, aber ich konnte sauber herum gehen und ich konnte noch meine Sachen in Ordnung halten. Und hier habe ich...hier waren wir fünf hundert (500) Mädels in einem Saal. Gekommen sind noch fünf hundert (500), noch zwei hundert (200), noch hundert (100)...jeden Tag...von allen, Ungarn, ungarische Leute und russische Leute und polnische Leute...alles verschiedene, alte Leute, gesunde Leute und kranke Leute, alles zusammen, Einer bei dem Anderen. Einer hat Läuse gehabt, die Zweite hat nicht gehabt...die Eine hat wieder eine Weile nicht gehabt. Und so war das schrecklich, schrecklich! Und so sind wir monatelang auf dem schmutzigen, verschmutzten Fußboden gesessen.
David Boder: Haben Sie nicht gearbeitet in Belsen?
Fela Nichthauser: Absolut nicht. Dort haben gearbeitet nur die starken russischen, nicht die russischen...die Ukrainer.
David Boder: Frauen?
Fela Nichthauser: Ja, die Frauen und die waren stark—so fünf und zwanzig (25) bis dreißig (30) Jahre alt.
David Boder: Und was haben die gearbeitet?
Fela Nichthauser: Die haben im Feld gearbeitet, im Garten. Es war ein sehr, sehr großes Lager, das hat sich auf Kilometer gezogen und früher war das ein, hm,...das waren...Militär hat dort gewohnt, die Soldaten und später hat man gemacht daraus ein Konzentrationslager. Dort hat man die Leute konzentriert, um sie zum...Tod bringen.
David Boder: Hm.
Fela Nichthauser: Dort war ein Krematorium, wo man nur tote Leute ge...verbrannt hat. Sie haben nicht gebraucht die Lebendigen zu verbrennen, weil es sind Tausende und Tausende jeden Tag vor dem Block gelegen, vom Typhus tot.
David Boder: In Ihrem Block?
Fela Nichthauser: In meinem Block und verschiedenen Blocken. Dann ich war nur ein paar Tage auf dem Block und man hat dann genommen einen Teil Mädels und sie haben gesagt, sie müssen gehen in einen anderen, in einen anderen Block. So sind wir dorthin gegangen, wir haben nicht gewusst wo. Eben dann haben wir erfahren, das war ein Block, da wurde dann aufgeschrieben auf dem Block „Hier herrscht der Tod“. Es war ein Typhus Block. Dort waren lauter alte Zigeuner und ungarische Leute und die waren Typhus-krank. Wir waren ganz gesund noch und wir haben ausgeschaut wie Menschen. Eben der Block hat uns zu allem Schlechten gebracht. Ich saß da mit Zigeunern, die waren ziemlich freundlich zu mir—das waren deutsche Zi...
David Boder: Zigeuner.
Fela Nichthauser: . . . deutsche Zigeuner, ja. Aber schmutzig war,...schrecklich schmutzig!
David Boder: Waren denn so viele Zigeuner da?
Fela Nichthauser: Nicht so viele Zigeuner, aber so viele Leute. Zigeuner waren nicht so viele, aber es war alles gemischt. Es waren schrecklich viele Leute.
David Boder: Und Sie waren dann in den Baracken, wo die Zigeuner...
Fela Nichthauser: Ja, ich war noch damals gesund, ich hab noch das Stückchen Decke hatte ich noch, das habe ich jeden Tag geklopft und geputzt . Und ich habe noch in meinem Vermögen gehabt eine, einen kleinen Kamm, eine Zahnbürste, Zahnpasta und meine Haarbürste.
David Boder: Zahnpasta haben Sie noch gehabt? Von wo haben Sie die Zahnpasta gehabt?
Fela Nichthauser: Zahnpasta haben wir manchmal bekommen im Lager, aber nicht Gute, so aber man hat sich können die Zähne putzen. Und sonst hab ich nichts gehabt und nichts mehr, nur einen Mantel und ein Stückchen Decke. Und das hab ich jeden Tag geputzt mit der Haarbürste.
David Boder: Hat man Sie am Tage draußen raus gelassen?
Fela Nichthauser: Nur vor dem Block. Es war abge...mit einem Steich..., mit einem Stacheldraht abge...
David Boder: Abgezäunt.
Fela Nichthauser: . . . abgezäunt, weil das war ein Typhus Block und das war ansteckend gewesen und da hat man nicht dürfen den anderen Menschen zu kommen.
David Boder: Ja. Und sind welche von ihren Mädels krank geworden?
Fela Nichthauser: Ob krank geworden? Wir sind fünf hundert (500) Mädels nach Belsen gekommen und es sind hundert zwei und dreißig (132) über geblieben. Für uns ist speziell eine Liste gewesen. Alle Anderen sind von Typhus gestorben oder von Schmutz. Bei mir hat es auch nicht viel gefehlt. Mit der Zeit - ich erinnere mich an den Tag, wo ich die ersten Läuse auf meiner, auf meiner Bluse gefunden habe. Ich wollte es nicht glauben. Ich habe damals geweint wie ein kleines Kind. Ich habe nie einen...Läuse auf mir gehabt und ich wollte nicht glauben, dass wirklich hier...Andere können haben, aber ich darf es doch nicht haben. Und da haben die Anderen, mit denen ich gesessen habe, da haben sie mich ausgelacht. Da haben sie gesagt: „Heute hast Du Eine, morgen wirst Du Zwei haben und in einer Woche wirst Du tausend haben!“ Und so war es. Dann nachher hatte ich schon keine Kraft die Läuse von mir weg zu nehmen, weil die haben herum spaziert, so wie Ameisen.
David Boder: Auf Ihrem Körper?
Fela Nichthauser: Ja, obwohl ich zwei Mal täglich meine Sachen durch geschaut habe, damit ich wenigstens fünf Minuten Ruhe habe. Aber in der Nacht konnte ich nicht schlafen. Man hat nicht geschlafen so mit die Füsse ausgezogen. Wir haben sitzend geschlafen, weil es war wenig Platz. Und so haben wir monatelang, wochenlang gesessen, ohne Essen. Letztens hat man kein Brot gegeben—sechs (6) Wochen kein Brot, nur ein bisschen Suppe, wenn man das Suppe nennen kann. Wasser mit Kohlrüben, ohne Salz.
David Boder: Das haben Sie bekommen?
Fela Nichthauser: Ja. Das hat man gegeben—einmal täglich eine ganz kleine Tasse und man hat sich müssen noch schlagen damit. Und schreckliche Szenen hat man dort gesehen—so Schreckliche! Meine ganzen Freundinnen, die sind dort gewesen, mit denen ich im Lager war, ich wollte nicht glauben, so wunderschöne Mädels und junge Mädel. Im Lager haben wir noch manches Mal so Humor gehabt, haben wir getanzt, haben wir verschiedene Vorstellungen gemacht. Und viele sind sehr fähige Mädels gewesen, ich war auch bei denen. Wir haben, zum Beispiel, viele Vorstellungen gemacht und wenn ein Mädel Geburtstag hat gehabt, was immer vorbereitet und gesungen oder einen Vers gedichtet oder irgend etwas, das Anderen das Leben selbst erfreut. Und da eben, da habe ich mich alles selbst erinnert, wo ich in Belsen war. Ich habe die selben Mädels gesehen, die mit mir getanzt haben, die mit mir gesungen haben und die so fröhlich waren, so voll Lebensmut trotz der Schwere, die wir im Leben hatten. Wir haben doch immer geglaubt an die Freiheit. Und jetzt ist da so Eine nach der Anderen gestorben. Das war so schrecklich, so peinlich, dass man das mit Worten wirklich nicht schildern kann.
David Boder: Wo sind sie gestorben? In dem...(unverständlich—beide sprechen)
Fela Nichthauser: In dem Lager, im selben Block, wo ich war. Das Gesicht von jedem Mädel, das gestorben sollte, hat sich so verändert, man hat sofort gewusst, dass dieses Mädel in ein paar Minuten wird sterben. Nur vom Hunger und vom Schmutz. Ich konnte, zum Beispiel, wie oft hat man mich gerufen, ich soll gehen. Man hat die Anderen auch gerufen:“ Komm zu mir.“ Ich konnte nicht, weil ich habe gewusst, mir wird das Herz platzen, wenn ich sehe die ganzen...weil man hat die Menschen überhaupt nicht gesehen. Nur die Augen, die Läuse und die Läuse...man hat nichts gesehen...nur die Läuse. Und so ganz abgerissen, kein Kleid...
David Boder: Was meinen Sie mit Läuse, nur Läuse?
Fela Nichthauser: Keinen Menschen...voll Läuse auf dem Menschen, ja. Man hat jetzt die Sachen nachgeschaut, jetzt abgeputzt, jetzt das Stückchen Decke ausgeklopft. Man hat sich hin gesetzt...in einer Weile wieder das Selbe. Man hat doch schreckliche Krätze gehabt. Ich auch nach der Freiheit habe ich auch Krätze gehabt, der ganze Leib bedeckt mit offene Wunden, es war schrecklich, wir haben schon nicht geglaubt, dass wir davon heraus kommen. Viele Mädels, viele meiner Freundinnen waren verrückt geworden. Man hat geschrieen in der Nacht „Wo bin ich?“. Man hat gerufen Mama, man hat gerufen Bruder. Man hat die Ohren zu ge..., zu ge...
David Boder: Zu gemacht.
Fela Nichthauser: . . . zugemacht, ja damit man es nicht hört. Ja, man wollte es nicht glauben. Und es sind Verschiedene, die Deutschen sind gekommen...die deutschen Frauen sind zu uns gekommen jeden Tag zum Appell hat man uns gerufen. Ich kann mich erinnern an Irma Grese, die kenn ich persönlich. Ich weiß nicht, ob Sie von ihr gehört haben.
David Boder: Welche Irma Grese?
Fela Nichthauser: Irma Grese, die jetzt aufgehängt worden ist.
David Boder: Oh, die, die aufge...
Fela Nichthauser: Ja, die von Belsen.
David Boder: Ja, nun?
Fela Nichthauser: Die hab ich persönlich gekannt. Ich hab nicht gewusst, dass sie Irma Grese heißt. Jetzt nach der Befreiung hab ich ihr Bild gesehen in der Zeitung,...
David Boder: Ja?
Fela Nichthauser: Man hat Verschiedenes beschrieben, wie sie angezogen war und was für ein Gesicht hat sie, da hab ich gewusst, dass das sie ist. Ich kann mich noch ganz gut erinnern.
David Boder: Nun?
Fela Nichthauser: Sie hat mit uns, mit unserem Block speziell, so verschiedene schreckliche Szenen gemacht. Ihr Gesicht, wissen Sie, war so schön, große, blaue Augen und schöne, goldene Haare und schön angezogen, so SS Anzug gehabt und einen Stecken in der Hand und einen ganz großen Hund. Sie ist jeden Tag zu uns gekommen und bevor sie gekommen ist, hat man müssen warten drei (3), vier (4) Stunden. Und wir wurden um acht (8) Uhr oder sieben (7) Uhr früh auf den Appell Platz gerufen...ohne Waschen, ohne Essen—ohne Nichts. Und wir mussten im Regen oder Schnee und im Frost, war ganz egal, mussten wir zu vier (4) oder zu fünf (5) stehen. Und die Block Älteste, die im Block war, hat auf sie gewartet und wir mussten dort stehen, wir durften uns nicht hin setzen. Einige wollten auf den nassen Fußboden sich hin setzen—auf den nassen Boden—durfte man nicht, man musste so auf Achtung stehen bis sie kommt. Dann ist sie gekommen. Sie hat einmal uns verboten irgend etwas auf dem Kopf zu haben. Und man hat...
David Boder: Was meinen Sie „irgend etwas auf dem Kopf“?
Fela Nichthauser: Ein Tuch oder eine Decke, ja. Tuch haben wir nicht gehabt, weil man hat uns doch alles weg genommen, aber man hatte so kleine Stückchen, was man hat abgeschnitten von der Bettdecke, der grauen Bettdecke. Weil man ist glücklich gewesen, dass man das Stückchen hat. Man hat doch gestanden so stundenlang auf dem Schnee oder im Regen und da hat man sich das so über den Kopf geworfen. Viele waren so. Und sie hat das verboten. Und diese Mädel, die die das gemacht haben, haben sich versteckt nach hinten. Sie sind nicht als Erste gestanden, sondern als Fünfte. Und dann ist sie gegangen und hat gezählt. Sie konnte nicht sehen so von Weitem, so wir...man zählt mit die Augen. Sie musste auf...jeden Kopf die Peitsche legen, so hat sie gezählt...Eine nach dem Anderen, wie...
David Boder: Hat sie Sie geschlagen mit der Peitsche?
Fela Nichthauser: . . . so eins, zwei, drei...
David Boder: Ja.
Fela Nichthauser: . . . und keiner durfte sich nicht rühren. Und wenn sie hat bemerkt, dass Eine eben von uns hat gehabt das Stückchen Decke auf dem Kopf, ist sie sofort mit einem...mit einem Lächeln zu gegangen und hat herunter gerissen diese Decke mit dem Mensch zusammen. Dann hat sie den Hund gerufen, nicht dass der Hund soll beißen, sondern nur Lärm machen und Angst machen. Und das war schlimmer als das Beißen, dass der Mensch...
David Boder: Was hat der Hund getan?
Fela Nichthauser: So gesprungen, wissen Sie, und so die Zähne so als möchte er...schon beißen würde, beißen hat sie ihm nicht erlaubt. Weil sie wollte es nicht, sie wollte nur Angst und Schreck machen, das war viel schlimmer...
David Boder: Ja, das war (unverständlich—beide sprechen)...
Fela Nichthauser: . . . und das war doch viel schlimmer.
David Boder: Ah hm.
Fela Nichthauser: Und da hat sie eben vom Kopf diese Decke mit dem Menschen runter gerissen und noch gestoßen und mit der Peitsche geschlagen. Sie soll nächstes Mal wissen, dass sie es nicht machen darf, was man ihr sagt. Und dann, wenn sie hat mit der „Blokova“ gesprochen, der Block Ältesten...
David Boder: . . . mit der Block Ältesten...
Fela Nichthauser: . . . Block Ältesten gesprochen, hat sie gesprochen...hat sie gefragt, hm, wie viele Menschen hast du, wie Viele sind gestorben und so weiter, hat sie so eine schönes Gesicht gezeigt, so ein gutes Gesicht...wirklich, es könnte niemand sagen, dass sie vor einer Weile solche Szenen gemacht hat, so schlecht, so un...so unbarmherzig für die anderen Menschen sein kann. Als ob wir waren etwas...etwas Ärgeres als die Block Älteste. Ich kann nur sagen, dass die Block Älteste war...nichts Anderes war, als früher vor dem Krieg, haben sie Zwiebel oder Knoblauch auf der Strasse verkauft. Und jetzt waren sie große Personen zu– eben bei uns im Lager! Und die...eben die Mädels, also nicht Menschen, aber schon wirklich Tiere, schon ganz, ganz zu Grunde gebrachte Menschen...die waren einmal Menschen, die haben bestimmt sich gebildet, die sind bestimmt auf die Universität gegangen oder Gymnasium...
David Boder: Sie meinen...
Fela Nichthauser: . . . oder irgend was, ich sprich nicht von mir...
David Boder: Sie meinen diese SS?
Fela Nichthauser: Nein—ja diese SS, aber ich spreche jetzt von den Menschen, die jetzt schon keine Menschen waren, die waren sicher Menschen vor dem Krieg, die haben...
David Boder: Sie meinen die Häftlinge?
Fela Nichthauser: Die Häftlinge natürlich. Man hat uns doch nicht als Menschen behandelt. Weil man hat geglaubt wir sind Juden, wir sind bestimmt in Kellern geboren oder irgendwo, keine Mutti hat und so nicht gehabt. Wir wissen nicht, was ein weißes Bett ist. Wir wissen nicht, was eine gute Suppe ist. Das...das haben sie alles geglaubt. Und ich sage eben, die ganzen Block Ältesten, die mit uns...die uns geschlagen haben, die uns gequält haben, die waren nichts anderes als solche...noch schlimmer wie ein Dienstmädel, sicher. Was uns eben weh getan hat, ist dass sie uns so niedrig gemacht haben. Wenn wir wollten raus gehen haben wir uns müssen melden, ob wir raus gehen dürfen. Achtung stehen und sagen: „Frau Lagerführerin“ oder irgend wie so sagen, hat abgehängt von wer die SS Frau war. Und das hat abgehangen, wenn sie hat gesagt ja, das war gut...
David Boder: Was heißt raus gehen, was meinen Sie damit?
Fela Nichthauser: Hm, hm, , zur, hm, Kabine.
David Boder: Zur Toilette?
Fela Nichthauser: Zur Toilette und wollte sie sagen ja, gut. Wollte Sie sagen nein, mussten wir zurück gehen. Hat nichts geholfen. Und dann konnten sie mit uns machen, was sie wollten. Also das heißt, wir sind weiter in dem Block gewesen, auf dem, auf dem schmutzigen Fußboden gelegen, nichts gegessen, nur gewartet von früh bis abends, von abends bis früh. Wir haben nur gehört das Schießen.
David Boder: Nun erlauben Sie mir eine Frage.
Fela Nichthauser: Bitte.
David Boder: Und wo sind jetzt ihre Eltern?
Fela Nichthauser: Mein Papa war, seit dieser Zeit, wo er genommen wurde, haben wir noch Post von ihm bekommen, Ich habe ihm noch Päckchen geschickt. Dann das letzte Lager war Dachau und seit dieser Zeit, wo Postsperre war im ganzen Lager, wo man nicht schreiben durfte, ist jede Spur von ihm verloren—ich weiß nichts mehr. Und meine Mutti meint, er lebt sicher nicht, weil jetzt hat er schon gegen sechzig (60) Jahre. Und meine Mutti hat jetzt gegen vier und fünfzig (54) oder fünf und fünfzig (55)...
David Boder: Und wo ist sie?
Fela Nichthauser: Sie ist in Auschwitz, sie lebt sicher nicht, denn sonst...bis heute...
David Boder: Wurde sie nach Auschwitz geschickt?
Fela Nichthauser: . . . geschickt.
David Boder: Haben Sie das gewusst?
Fela Nichthauser: Ja, natürlich, der ganze Transport der Frauen ist nach Auschwitz gegangen.
David Boder: Ist nach Auschwitz gegangen und, hm,...
Fela Nichthauser: Meine älteste Schwester war mit ihrem Mann in Lemberg.
David Boder: Ja.
Fela Nichthauser: Und während des Krieges habe ich dort hin Lagerpäckchen von ihr bekommen und Briefe und seit diese...auf einmal hört das auf und schreckliche Sachen haben dann passiert und die Deutschen haben Leute ermordet und seit dem weiß ich auch nichts von ihr bis heute. Das ist schon sieben (7) Jahre oder acht (8) Jahre, seitdem habe ich meine Schwester nicht gesehen. Und mein ältester Bruder, der auch verheiratet ist, hatte einen kleinen Sohn von zwei (2) Jahren, wo der im zwei und vierziger (42) Jahr in Tarnow noch gewohnt hat, ist auch ausgesiedelt—auf die Ukraine geschickt, und auch nicht mehr lebt und...
David Boder: Und über das Kind wissen Sie auch nicht?
Fela Nichthauser: Auch das Kind wurde doch mit geschleppt und...
David Boder: Ja. Und sagen Sie mal und wie wurden Sie befreit?
Fela Nichthauser: Ich wurde befreit nach die...
David Boder: In Belsen?
Fela Nichthauser: . . . in Belsen am fünfzehnten April.
David Boder: Sagen Sie mir was über diesen Tag oder den Tag bevor dieser Befreiung. Was hat vorgegangen?
Fela Nichthauser: Ich kann Ihnen sagen, ich habe Ihnen nicht erzählt einen halben Teil von dem, was ich will und erlebt habe. Glauben Sie mir, dass in diesen drei ein halb (3 ½ ) Jahren könnte ich Ihnen nicht so viel erzählen, als von den einigen Monaten, die ich in Belsen war. Nicht nur von den Leuten, was ich gesehen habe, aber von mir selbst auch. Schrecklich—man konnte...man kann das nicht mit Worten schildern, wenn man das selber nicht erlebt. Ich habe da ausgeschaut, wie eine...wie eine siebzig (70) jährige alte Frau. Ich konnte mich nicht bewegen. Ich habe...ich bin ganz...ganz abgemagert gewesen, nicht gewaschen, wochenlang sich nicht ausgezogen. So in dem...in dem einen Kleid und in dem Mantel so bin ich auf dem Fußboden gelegen. Ich...ich wollte Wasser zum Trinken, konnte ich nicht. Durchfall habe ich gehabt zwei (2) Monate. Ich hab dann Typhus gehabt...bekommen.
David Boder: Sie haben Typhus gehabt?
Fela Nichthauser: Ja, natürlich. Ich habe Durchfall gehabt, dass ich nicht eine Minute im Block sein...
David Boder: War das Flecktyphus oder Magentyphus?
Fela Nichthauser: Das war Magentyphus.
David Boder: Ja.
Fela Nichthauser: Das war vom Hunger.
David Boder: Und im...wo...wo waren Sie gelegen? Im Hospital?
Fela Nichthauser: Nein, absolut nicht.
David Boder: Also in der Baracke?
Fela Nichthauser: Man hat uns doch überhaupt nicht gerettet. Man hat gewusst, dass dort viele, viele Leute Typhus krank sind und doch...sie wollten es...(unverständlich—beide sprechen). Gut man hat Offiziere jeden Tag und auch Soldaten und haben geguckt, dass die Verstorbenen liegen vor dem Block und man hat die sofort transportiert vor dem Krematorium. Und manches Mal...
David Boder: Was heißt vor dem Block? Hat man die Gestorbenen raus gegeben?
Fela Nichthauser: Ja. Da sind so speziell so vier (4) Frauen gewesen, vier (4) ungarische Frauen, die sich mit dem beschäftigt haben. Wenn Eine bei uns gestorben ist, hat man das sofort gesagt. Und die vier (4) Frauen haben dafür bekommen ein bisschen Suppe, weil sie es gemacht haben. Sie waren noch ziemlich stark. Da haben sie eine graue Decke genommen, dann haben sie den toten Menschen in die Decke herein gegeben und dann vor geschmissen...hm, vor den Block geschmissen. Und so hat das gelegen - manches Mal zwei (2) Wochen, drei (3) Wochen—so bis sich...bis sich gesammelt haben dreißig (30), fünfzig (50), hundert (100), zwei hundert (200) Tote. Bis man das...bis die gekommen sind...die Juden...Männer und haben es...unter einer Wache...haben es transportiert zum Krematorium. Und oftmals bin ich vor dem Krematorium vorbei gegangen...
David Boder: Was meinen Sie ‚die Toten sind viele Wochen draußen gelegen’?
Fela Nichthauser: Ja, die sind gelegen ohne nichts.
David Boder: Ja.
Fela Nichthauser: Und oftmals bin ich da vorbei gegangen vor dem Krematorium, denn manches Mal mussten wir den Kessel mit der Suppe holen—jeden Tag waren Andere—und da sind wir bei dem Krematorium gegangen und haben gesehen Berge und Berge, man konnte es nicht glauben, von Toten...von Toten, wo das Krematorium nicht nachkommen konnte. Es waren so viele Tote, dass lauter Berge waren von dem...von der...eben von der Luft hat man...waren die ganzen Krankheiten. Die Typhus Krankheiten, das war doch alles im Lager und es sind viele, viel Tausende gewesen, die sich bewegen konnten. Die sind raus gegangen, um eine Kartoffelschale zu suchen oder um irgend was bitten, da sind doch die Leute neben der Küche und da hat man doch bitten können, man soll ein bisschen Suppe geben. Haben sie doch gesehen die alle, alle die schrecklichen Sachen...
David Boder: Und wer hat sie befreit [unverständlich]?
Fela Nichthauser: Engländer. Im,...hm, das war am fünfzehnten (15.) April, wo wir überhaupt nicht erwartet haben und wir überhaupt nicht gewusst haben, dass die Freiheit so nahe ist und dass sie zu uns kommt. Wir haben doch mit Niemandem Kontakt gehabt. Und auf einmal haben wir gesehen, dass die...alle SS Männer und SS Frauen haben angefangen zu tragen weiße Bänder auf den Armen.
David Boder: Das heißt was?
Fela Nichthauser: Armbänder...also das heißt, dass sie sich...
David Boder: Ergeben.
Fela Nichthauser: . . . ergeben.